homeboy q
j'aimerais que vous me disiez combien de disques
avez-vous vendu avec votre nom dessus en tant que
compositeur ou
producteur de ranger oh wow
je ne sais pas
environ cent millions ou quelque chose que
hé mec
et de retour  le bloc tu racontes 40 ans
de musique noire en 57 minutes c'est
vraiment ton empreinte autobiographique
ouais je dirais que revenir sur le bloc
serait euh comme une
empreinte autobiographique c'est euh les 40 dernières années de
ma vie
musicalement tu sais tu aurais pu appeler
cet album par courtoisie de avez-vous eu
des problèmes pour obtenir légalement toutes ces
personnes que j'ai appelées et j'ai dit que
j'aimerais que vous
chantiez ou jouiez sur ce numéro, ils ont dit à
quelle heure
ce n'était pas un problème quelques personnes sur
lesquelles je voulais être  l'album ne pouvait
pas être lionel richie était censé
chanter sur l'album et
euh il a dû subir une opération à la
gorge et stevie wonder euh était hors de la
ville alors
maintenant pensez-vous vraiment que les hip hoppers sont
créatifs comme les bee boppers et les rockers oui
je  pense que je pense ra  ppers sont sont l'une
des choses les plus créatives qui se soient
produites depuis le rock and roll et le jazz
parce que premièrement, ils ont une
énergie que rien d'
autre n'a aujourd'hui
euh ils ont affaire à beaucoup de
rythmes des années 70 et il y a  beaucoup de
choses high-tech comme le
sample et
euh
mais euh c'est intéressant parce que j'ai rencontré
ella cool j environ quatre ans à new york
et il m'a posé une question qui m'a fait
penser qu'il a dit à quoi pensent les chanteurs et les
musiciens  nous les rappeurs et
c'est la première fois que je
considère qu'ils ne se considèrent pas comme des
musiciens ou des chanteurs, ils sont comme
une autre entité et euh d'une certaine manière ils le sont
parce qu'ils ne traitent que du rythme,
je suis un peu curieux alors pourquoi pas
Michael Jackson chante sur l'album,
il a dit que le président de sa société
ne voulait pas qu'il chante sur mon disque, vous
n'étiez pas tous les deux un peu
déçus sur le plan de la créativité
et des ventes sur le mauvais
album déçus avec 22 millions d'albums non
pas du tout
je moi  une si vous regardez la relation avec
un
thriller qui est de 40 millions mais c'est
euh c'est de la
folie de penser que vous allez
refaire ça 22 millions d'albums c'est beaucoup de
disques
je ne suis pas je n'ai pas été déçu j'ai été
dans le business depuis trop longtemps pour être
déçu avec 22 millions
2 millions c'est bien savez vous quelque chose
sur l'histoire de la récente
conversion de michael à l'islam incroyable je n'en ai jamais
entendu parler c'est une nouvelle pour moi
vous plaisantez hein vous dites que kevin
campbell vous rappelle  de stephen et
michael quand ils avaient à peu près le même
âge 12 ans oui j'ai rencontré stevie euh au
théâtre apollo quand il avait 12 ans
et j'ai rencontré michael jackson je pense que c'est
la maison de sammy davis quand il avait 12
ans et c'est une sorte de  un symbole
que kevin avait 12 ans aussi, donc à
ce moment-là, je pense en connaître un quand j'en vois
un
et je pense que je pense que kevin en a autant ou
plus que euh michael avait quand il avait 12
ans
et il est vraiment gentil
pensez-vous  il produira jamais le prince
i  je ne sais pas qu'il m'a demandé j'ai demandé à
bruce d'être sur l'album aussi pour jouer de la
guitare et il a dit euh il ne voulait pas
faire ça parce qu'il voulait que je produise
un album entier avec lui mais ça dépend
du temps pourrait  vous me dites qui était cette dame
nadia boulanger avec qui vous êtes venu
travailler en france euh recommandé par
lalo schiffer
nadi jay était je dirais probablement le
professeur de composition le plus renommé
que le monde ait jamais vu vraiment elle
euh
elle lui a appris à copeland elle  a enseigné à la
classe philip
leonard bernstein à beaucoup de gens elle
était l'amie de revell
et l'amie de stevenson en fait j'ai
rencontré hugo stravinsky chez elle sur
francis rubalu
et
il m'a fallu beaucoup de temps pour vraiment absorber
toute la sagesse qu'elle m'a donnée
parce que quand je suis venu chez elle j'étais un bee
bopper
et euh j'étais difficile à
discipliner en tant que musicien classique
parce que je ne voulais pas vraiment être un
musicien classique je voulais
comprendre la composition mais pas être un
musicien classique
et
comme recen  Il y a cinq et six ans,
beaucoup de choses qu'elle m'a dites maintenant
commencent à devenir vraiment claires et à avoir un
sens, comme vous n'avez pas de liberté dans la
musique tant que vous n'avez pas une restriction totale,
vous vous restreignez et établissez
la périphérie et puis  vous avez la liberté
dans la musique et c'est vrai parce que si vous
pouvez jouer tout ce que vous voulez, vous
ne jouez rien
avec des disques de brocoli, le bon endroit
pour faire vos premiers pas en tant que
ranger professionnel, c'était un
endroit parfait pour moi parce
qu'à l'
époque  en 1957,
euh, je travaillais beaucoup comme arrangeur
pour des groupes de jazz et des petites sections de cuivres de jazz
, mais à cette époque, ils ne
laissaient pas les
arrangeurs noirs écrire pour les cordes
, alors j'ai rebondi sur la France et
j'avais des cordes dans le couloir.  nous
avions 12 jellos
et 62
sections de cordes ou 62
sections de cordes parfois et j'ai vraiment eu une
bonne opportunité d'écrire
pour beaucoup de types de musique différents à
paris
pendant les deux années que tu as passées à paris
tu as eu une chance  pour rencontrer la violence de boris,
oui, il était une personne incroyable, euh,
créée, je veux dire qu'il n'avait pas de
frontières, c'est ce que j'aimais chez lui,
il était très jeune quand il est mort,
mais je me souviens qu'il a écrit les paroles d'une
chanson
que
Cannonball a complètement composée, appelée sermonette et  j'ai été
surpris par le titre qu'il lui a
donné césar croyondu
et c'était incroyable parce qu'il disait à
la fin
euh
il y a tellement de jalousie et de haine et de
douleur dans le monde que j'aspire au
jour où la mort de mère m'emporte dans
ses bras  et il semblait que c'était une
sorte de déclaration prophétique dans ses
paroles c'était un génie
est-ce que l'opération cérébrale que vous avez subie en
1974 est-ce que ça a changé votre
vie de toute façon après oui
ça m'a fait euh comprendre qu'il
n'y a que
euh 25 000 jours
pour vraiment  faites tout
approximativement et vous n'avez pas pour toujours
et
vous devriez dire aux gens ce que vous ressentez
ce que vous ressentez vraiment à ce moment-là et ne pas
essayer d'être cool et retenir vos émotions
et et que vous devriez
avoir un  attitude à propos de la vie
que je suis désolé d'avoir fait plutôt que j'aurais aimé avoir
hé mec c'est quoi ton problème pourquoi
tu ne portes pas ton ruban rouge
[Musique]
la rosette
bleue